well
holding your
waist
you're gonna get counter
so you have to in this case check that
arm
you have a couple options you can check
it in boom it
uh you could check it out to the outside
he cannot grab you you can't be so naive
that you're just here with his one arm
fighting
it wasn't demonstrated that way you're
not watching
secondly i don't ever hit someone
this is a one hand
a normal what you call
[Music]
with the same argument as the throwing
arm
is going to do it
so you're not overpower people you do
not overpower people then they they have
to be smaller and weaker than you
pay attention more
so you have a lot of passes you pass to
get to control points it's no different
uh
in your
the side control escapes we were working
today you you're going to pass some
control points okay
uh so here i'm gonna pass from
it's not him grabbing me if don't grab
open your hand
okay it's a control point with that
adhesion
so the adhesion
okay
even though his fingers are closed i'm
actually controlling him
inside palm
to my forearm and i'm going to pass this
control point to the
or pass
boom there it is
then i use the other part of my forearm
and that's where the coated vest comes
and then
pass today
should it be external no it shouldn't be
in fact it was so internal the first
time you guys didn't even see it okay so
i don't want to go yeah yeah yeah you
can you can go like this
[Music]
okay but it should it's more internal so
it won't touch
you
okay
i don't need to go here
and then
it's all in turn all internal circular
edges
um
so i'm going in
oh